c'est une crise diplomatique qui n'en
finit pas et même à trois mois de la
présidentielle américaine donald trump a
de nouveau ravivé les tensions entre les
etats-unis et l'iran mercredi dernier il
annoncé son intention de rétablir la
quasi-totalité des sanctions contre la
république islamique
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé au secrétaire
d'état mme knight pompéo de notifier au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu que les
états unis entendent rétablir
pratiquement toutes les sanctions des
nations unies contre l'iran ce jusque là
suspendu le lendemain de cette annonce
le secrétaire d'état américain ainsi je
cite notifier au conseil de sécurité les
violations présumées des engagements
iranien prévu par l'accord conclu à
vienne en 2015 mike pompéo a également
accusé les pays signataires de manquer
de fermeté face à téhéran en refusant de
prolonger l'embargo sur les ventes
d'armes à l'iran
nos actions d'aujourd'hui ne devrait
surprendre personne
notre équipe a déployé tous les efforts
diplomatiques possibles depuis
maintenant près de deux ans pour
renouveler cet embargo sur les armes
aucun pays à l'exception des états unis
nous le courage et la conviction de
proposer une résolution au lieu de cela
ils ont choisi de se ranger du côté des
ayatollahs leurs actions mettent en
danger les populations de l'irak du
yémen du liban de la syrie même leurs
propres citoyens pour rétablir ces
sanctions les états unis expliquent
qu'ils vont déclencher un mécanisme
appelé snap bac une possibilité offerte
aux participants à l'accord de vienne
qui inclut la chine la russie la france
le royaume uni l'allemagne l'union
européenne et l'iran mais cette
procédure est juridiquement compliqué
validé après le retrait américain de
cette entente en 2018
paris berlin londres moscou et pékin ont
assuré ne pas soutenir cette initiative
américaine
de son côté téhéran assure compter sur
l'onu pour contrer les etats-unis l'iran
attend du secrétaire général et des
états membres du conseil de sécurité
qu'ils s'acquittent de leurs obligations
légales et contre le comportement
voillot de l'administration américaine
les états unis ne sont plus signataires
de l'accord sur le nucléaire et la
décision de washington n'a aucun
fondement
malgré l'opposition internationale
nal trump pourrait néanmoins clamé dans
un mois que ces sanctions sont à nouveau
en vigueur contre l'iran le président
américain a déjà rétablis depuis 2018 et
même durci toutes les sanctions de
washington contre la république
islamique
en riposte les autorités iraniennes
avaient annoncé ne plus respecter leur
engagement de limiter leur programme
nucléaire notamment concernant
l'enrichissement d'uranium